c'est jimmy et je retrouve pour confiner
d'ici et d'ailleurs sur la première
aujourd'hui je propose de vivre un
véritable périple celui de jean jacques
pineau il est martiniquais et les
médecins il vit à bordeaux il a vécu une
sacrée aventure salut jean jacques
alors là tu as bordeaux en ce moment
mais tu reviens d'un long périple
effectué peut être bien on va dire un
contenu long périple de six mois ouais
du coup j'étais parti en année
sabbatique que pour découvrir l'amérique
du sud après un peu ce continent sur six
mois j'avais commencé par l'argentine
chili je savais faire un petit détour du
côté d'eads et le bac
cueillez la bolivie la colombie et puis
ils le paieront 1 avant de faire
l'équateur mais je suis retrouvé coincé
au pérou pérou à quel moment quand
c'était déjà bien déclarée l'épidémie
là-bas ou tout début
alors c'était vraiment le tout début en
fait je suis arrivé au paiement le 1er
mars
regarde quasiment aucun cas dans
l'amérique du sud à ce moment là c'était
l'europe qui commençait mais on suivait
pas trop je dois l'avouer est en fait au
fur et à mesure il ya commencé à voir
les premières mesures qui ont été mises
en place et le 15 le 15 mars donc à peu
près 15 jours après il ya une allocution
présidentielle sur toutes les télés du
monde était un petit peu de vent et là
le président s'est carrément que tel en
main au filet complètement tout le pays
fermeture des frontières
impossibilité de bouger et donc on s'est
retrouvé pour l'un c'est l'heure comment
t'as fait justement pour pour quitter le
pérou du coup alors initialement il y
avait pas tellement une solution puisque
moi je n'étais pas sur la capitale la
capitale sélima gt 1 570 km de la
capitale dans une ville qui s'appelle
ayacucho qui est petit il pas très
touristique assez grande mais pas très
touristique est en fait il n'y avait
aucune possibilité de la quitter puisque
les transports aériens l aéroport et des
transports terrestres par plus c'était
complètement coupées donc initialement
pas de solution en gros c'est on va
essayer de se rapprocher de l'ambassade
l'ambassade de france qui nous a rien
dit
inscrit en chez les différents réseaux
en particulier ariane pour pouvoir
essayer de trouver des solutions mais
malheureusement l'ambassade n'avait pas
du tout solution pour nous il n'avait
pas la main sur l'organisation de
transports lille pouvait rapatrier que
les gens qui étaient sur des grandes
villes dont climat ou alors cusco
arequipa qui sont d'autres grandes
villes du pérou nous initialement l'idée
c'est d'être de réflexion place et
attendent des instances secondaires non
on a commencé à voir les choses évoluer
il ya eu de plus en plus de restrictions
les quarts ont commencé à augmenter au
niveau du perron donc l'ambassade de
france nous a carrément dit écoutez il
faut que vous débrouiller de votre côté
on pourra vous faire une dérogation
déplacement mais par contre il faut que
vous trouviez une solution transitoire
on a regardé un petit mot sur les
réseaux sociaux on a trouvé d'autres
français on était 80 où il y en a 5
s'est regroupée à 5 pour décider de se
déplacer on a contacté l'alliance
européenne pour voir s'il y avait
d'autres européens
on en a retrouvé d'autres donc on a
formé un groupe de 8 avec une suisses un
allemand et un autrichien et sur les
médias sociaux on a contacté des agences
de tourisme pour savoir si
éventuellement les arrêts des bus de
dispo si elle était d'accord pour vous
rabattre et sur la capitale sur les
mains après avoir envoyé à peu près une
quinzaine de mails on a dû avoir cinq ou
six réponses donc de là on avait un trou
soffer il a fallu donc trouver un hôtel
sur l'image était d'accord pour
accueillir des français en intro rien
grâce à un peu nos réseaux d'autres
français qui avait quitté la capitale
avant et ensuite on s'est rapproché des
autorités d'ailleurs tout chaud donc au
niveau de la police touristique pour
pouvoir organiser tout ça donc en gros
ça nous a pris trois jours complets sur
les réseaux sur internet
enfin tout organiser on a eu notre
autorisation de circuler le 4 c'était un
samedi le 4 avril et le transport a été
organisée le 6 avril donc là on est
partis à 6 heures du matin
passage à la police est ensuite
direction les mains fallait compter dix
heures de route à peu près pas de pause
l'autorisé donc 10 heures quasiment
d'emblée on a une plusieurs arrêts sur
la route environ six ou sept
d'abord des à rave organisée par des
milices locales qui sont en fait des
groupes de paysans des groupes
d'agriculteurs en fait armées qui se
substituer à la police aux endroits où
il n'y a pas de police donc on a d'abord
passé un ou deux barrages comme ça c'est
un type qui est inquiétant on se
retrouve encerclé de personnes qui ont
des armes
on sait pas trop comment ça se passe
finalement on est passé plus on se
rapprochait des grands axes plus à ce
moment-là on arrivait sur des groupes
organisés dont il a été arrêté par
l'armée
plusieurs fois juste avant d'arriver sur
l'humain on avait un dernier contrôle
qui est un contre l'avis médical
le chauffeur et nous ils nous prenaient
la température posait quelques questions
et une fois qu'on était passé en fait on
avait accès à la capitale et enfin notre
hôtel où on était obligés d'être déposés
directement dans l'entrée de l'hôtel
donc voilà après dix heures de route on
a enfin rejoint la capitale où on est
resté trois jours donc une fois arrivé
on s'est tout de suite mis en lien avec
l'ambassade qui nous a instruits sur le
vol de rapatriement du 9 avril donc
jeudi 9 avril on mettait enfin sur un
vol d'air france vol gouvernemental
organisé par le ministère en accord avec
les autorités des pouvoirs mais on est
quand même content de voir que tout va
bien ça y est tu es entrée sur bordeaux
un peu précipitamment enfin j'espère que
tu gardé un bon souvenir de ce tour de
l'amérique latine quand même oui tout à
fait heureusement j'ai comme j'ai
commencé en novembre j'ai quand même eu
le temps de faire quatre mois et demi de
voyage sur les six mois et donc de
visiter cinq pays quasiment donc oui je
garde un très bon souvenir de cette
expérience j'espère pouvoir y retourner
et finalisé
les parties que j'ai pas pu faire s'il
fallait nous conseillez impayés en
particulier ce serait lequel
difficile de répondre parce qu'ils sont
tous très différents mais j'ai quand
même un gros coup de coeur pour pour la
bolivie en particulier pour ses paysages
incroyables qu'on peut avoir dans la
région qu'on appelle le sud il baise
avec le salar c'est vraiment un endroit
unique je pense pas qu'il y ait un
équivalent sur terre pour voir ce qu'on
va noter ça on va rajouter ça nous
destinations de voyage merci beaucoup
jean jacques pineau et puis surtout un
bon repos après tout ce périple et à
très bientôt en martinique je l'espère
dans d'autres circonstances bien
évidemment merci à très vite
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
s'était confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs avec
une sacrée aventure qu'a vécu jean
jacques pineau merci de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve très bientôt pour une
nouvelle rencontre une nouvelle
destination sur la première
[Musique]